using Anderson bench as a case study
what were the first steps in producing a
film the first steps well when we have
to the director and I have to get on the
same page on what type of movie we're
going to to make then what's the
approach in the budget how many days
we're going to shoot it in and then the
tone of it and then if all of those
stars align then we set out to
pragmatically put the project together
cast it and then come up with a schedule
and then shoot and fly people in and out
I like to start with the big pieces
first
so in Anderson bench the the one
location we shot out most was Anderson's
house so we started there it's always
easier to start outside because you if
it's not raining you film outside if it
is raining you go inside can i interject
real quick sure our first thing wasn't
we shot you in the house sorry what's
our philosophy well you have to start
before you can stop yep
it's hard to stop something that's in
motion it's hard to start something but
once you have it's hard to stop it once
it's in motion so the first thing we
shot and she shot it she was the camera
operator and it was me talking on the
phone with my nose running and the
glasses and a cigar and all that talking
to Anderson bench because I knew we were
gonna start shooting the next day we're
gonna do the movie the next day but we
had to start and we had to show the cast
and crew that snot dripping awful
disgusting scenes so that they would
understand the tone of Anderson bench
because they didn't know whether to
laugh or vomit when they saw those
dailies it's okay to both it is and cry
what was I doing for the days before
that before we did that with will out in
the driveway
what was I building but then Emma right
the machine couldn't film a movie
without Emma I mean we do everything so
we do art department we build we
character we do wardrobe everything is
talked about we shot at the back of that
machine because the the roller thing
where that people go down in it whoops
spoiler well that's all right
with the people it did sit promise film
right the promise of the premise wasn't
in yet so yeah we shot at the back well
it came in later that afternoon so we
installed it and then got to shoot
around the front of it but I mean we
just we just go for it yeah but you can
it's a good lesson in life you cannot
it's hard to stop something once you've
started so sometimes you have to just
start and you still need to be
strategically aligned yes that's the
critical thing having those
conversations director producer and
making sure that we are a writer and
that we're all making the same movie
mm-hmm
true and it's great because I trust him
a hundred percent and I trust her 100%
yeah she says no you can't do it that
way say okay how can we do it and vice
versa and if he says we're gonna finish
on time today don't worry about it we're
gonna finish on time and a probably
extra time yeah okay so fantasy and
reality merging one raining one in one
shooting out ideas one thing we can but
this has to happen I don't think that
it's raining each other end I really
think that both are abstract thinkers
and we both articulate life experience
as well
and I think that it's not about pulling
one back I think that it's just saying
this is what the boundaries are and you
got to maneuver through them and I feel
the same way
during I mean I have boundaries that I
have to maneuver to help him achieve his
goals you know so that it's a it's a
it's a tit-for-tat I was definitely not
a reining in it's like it's just each
other
guiding well I'll have some notion about
doing something and you'll say oh
there's a lot more time than that do it
do it do it how you really want to do it
cuz I'll say well I don't think we're I
think we're gonna run out of time said
you're not gonna run at a time you're
smarter than that do it the way you want
okay so I will and it's great fun it has
a great show a lot of experience with
that you know and I think that working
with filmmakers directors and producers
you
side of the coin and my son of the coin
have allowed us to be able to relax turn
Amin right HD actors relax people the
actors in these movies two things they
have it's not about fun I mean it fun
sounds like oh it's just fun and silly
and fun no it's fun because it's freeing
right it's fun like like winning excuse
me like winning a baseball game is fun I
don't care what they say losing a
baseball game not so much fun it's it's
it's the it's the thrill of doings of
having your you're not having your wings
clipped but having someone blow air up
underneath your wings like the song and
make you better than you are she makes
me better than I am I hope that I helped
make actors and set people everybody
better than they are we are we are we
are better together than we are apart
what's the synergy yeah we all have
synergy
you